I work more now because it is intoxicating what you were able to do with this stuff, which is kind of like, I've heard on podcast being like, wasn't this supposed to free us from work? And it's like, this is not work. I am Harry Potter with the elder, the elder one. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 276 recorded on February 26, 2006. My name is Connor. And today with my co-host, Bryce, we give a mini update on our AI and cursor usage, as well as chatabot running and more. Oh, I bought running shoes, by the way.
我现在工作得更多了，因为用这些东西能做到的事情实在太让人着迷了。我曾在播客里听到有人说：“这难道不应该把我们从工作中解放出来吗？”但我觉得，这根本不是工作。我简直就是拿着老魔杖的哈利·波特。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 276 期，录制于 2006 年 2 月 26 日。我是 Connor。今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 将简要更新一下我们在 AI 和 Cursor 使用方面的情况，以及聊天机器人的运行等等。哦，顺便说一下，我买了跑鞋。
I did buy running shoes. It is better. You were correct that I needed to own running shoes that you're going to run. This guy saying his knees hurt while he's running or whatever. And I'm like, well, what kind of running shoes are you running? He's like, oh, do I need running shoes? I'm just like, yes, you need running. I guess maybe I'm being, what's the word, elitist about running knowledge.
我确实买了跑鞋。这样好多了。你说得对，既然要跑步，我就得有双跑鞋。这家伙说他跑步时膝盖疼什么的，我就问他：“你穿什么跑鞋跑步？”他说：“哦，我需要跑鞋吗？”我当时就想，是的，你当然需要。我想我可能在跑步知识方面表现得有点……怎么说呢，精英主义了。
Maybe it's not a well-known fact. If you are having knee troubles, shin troubles, and you're trying to get into running, especially if you are above the age, we'll just call it 30. I'm not saying anything about people over 30, just when you're young, it doesn't really matter. The older you get, the more important it is you need a decent pair of riding shoes. The more cushion, the better for protecting joints and stuff. And if you've had a pair for like four years, you probably need a new pair. I get a new pair every like 600 kilometers.
也许这不是一个众所周知的事实。如果你有膝盖或胫骨方面的问题，并且正试图开始跑步，尤其是如果你年龄超过——我们就说是 30 岁吧。我不是针对 30 岁以上的人，只是当你年轻时，这确实没那么重要。年纪越大，拥有一双像样的跑鞋就越重要。缓冲越好，对关节的保护就越好。如果你一双鞋穿了四年，你可能需要换新的了。我大概每跑 600 公里就会换一双。
I won't say how frequently that is, but it's pretty frequent because you want to be able to exercise and walk for a long time. We may not be thinking about it in our 30s. But at some point when we get to 60s, 70s, 80s, you're going to start to have joint problems. And the better the shoes, the longer your joints are going to work for. So we did not end up doing the 5K on Valentine's Day because Ramona was very sick and it was very cold. And I could not make the sale ongoing through with it. But we are going to sign up for some other 5K. But I stopped running for a little bit after the first snowstorm in New York.
我就不说这频率有多高了，但确实挺频繁的，因为你希望能够长期坚持锻炼和行走。我们在 30 多岁时可能不会考虑这些，但到了 60、70、80 岁时，关节问题就会开始出现。鞋子越好，你的关节就能用得越久。所以我们最终没能在情人节那天完成 5 公里跑，因为 Ramona 病得很重，而且天气非常冷。我没法坚持完成那个目标。但我们打算报名参加其他的 5 公里比赛。不过在纽约第一场暴风雪之后，我停跑了一段时间。
and it's been hard for me to get back into it. Part of the problem is it's been too cold for Ramona to come running with me. And I am not as motivated to run when my girlfriend is not there to embarrass me by running a lot faster than me. So I keep telling her, you need to come back and start running with me again because it will be better for me if, like, you are there to force me to keep going. You just got to run enough until you get addicted to it. I have a race on Sunday called the Chili Half Marathon, which I've run twice. before and it's usually been right above freezing you know zero degrees for Canadians 32 for Americans I should say Canadians and the rest of the world and this Sunday it's
要重新开始跑步对我来说很难。部分原因是天气太冷了，Ramona 没法和我一起跑。当我的女朋友不在身边，没法通过跑得比我快来让我感到羞愧时，我的跑步动力就没那么足了。所以我一直跟她说，你得回来跟我一起跑，因为如果你在场逼着我继续跑，对我来说会更好。你只需要跑得足够多，直到上瘾为止。我周日有一场比赛叫“辣椒半程马拉松”，我之前跑过两次。以前气温通常在冰点以上，你知道，对加拿大人来说是 0 度，对美国人来说是 32 华氏度，我应该说对加拿大人和世界其他地方的人来说是 0 度，而这个周日……
supposed to be minus 12 feels like minus 18 which is got to be like potentially below zero for Fahrenheit folks and I'm very unexcited about it but you sign up for it you got to do it only one time in my race have I ever missed a race and it's because I was definitely ill because my nephew Franklin gave me some virus which made it impossible to leave bed for like a couple days. One of the big factors in us canceling was a misperception about the timing that I only realized at the last minute, which is Ramona's been taking these acting and then these speech classes and she has one on Saturday.
预计气温是零下 12 度，体感零下 18 度，这对华氏度用户来说可能低于零度了，我对此一点也不兴奋，但既然报了名就得去跑。我参加比赛以来只缺席过一次，那是因为我确实病了，我侄子 Franklin 传染给我一种病毒，让我好几天都下不了床。我们取消比赛的一个重要因素是对时间的误解，我直到最后一刻才意识到，那就是 Ramona 一直在参加表演课和演讲课，她周六有一节课。
And we signed up for the race and they said like, the starting time was like at 8 a.m. And I'm like, that's great. Like 8 a.m. 30, like a 5K will take like, you know, like 30. minutes, you know, tops for us. So then we'll be done and shall have time to get to our class at noon. And then I realize that they probably don't have all the people start at the same time. And we, the like very inexperienced runners are probably not starting in the first group, which is probably the like professional or very fast runners who have run a lot before. So we probably would not, it would like not have been possible for us to have done that anyways,
我们报名参加比赛时，他们说起跑时间是早上 8 点。我想，那太好了。早上 8 点半，5 公里对我们来说顶多跑 30 分钟。这样我们跑完就有时间赶去参加中午的课了。后来我意识到，他们可能不会让所有人同时起跑。而我们这些非常缺乏经验的跑者，可能不会在第一组起跑，第一组通常是那些跑过很多次的专业选手或速度很快的人。所以无论如何，我们可能都无法做到那样。
probably. Yeah, that makes sense. Well, I look forward to your future race, your future times. and I'm glad you got running shoes. I have a question for you. Hey, technical question, not related to our other stuff we have going on, which is, have you started playing around
可能吧。是的，这说得通。好吧，我很期待你未来的比赛和成绩。很高兴你买了跑鞋。我有个问题要问你。嘿，是个技术问题，和我们正在做的其他事情无关，那就是，你开始尝试使用 Claude Code 了吗？没有。虽然我们可以聊聊这个，但我会把它剪辑到下一期节目里，伙计们，因为有很多内容……所以这是预告，Bryce，因为我今天没时间录制……
with Claude Code at all yet? No. Although we can chat about this, I'm going to cut it into the next episode, folks, because there's a lot of, so here's the preview, Bryce, because I don't have time to record
……几个小时。Bryce 和我下周某个时候会录制，到时候会有很多内容。我们得聊聊 Parrot。我们得聊聊 Raybox。我一直渴望聊聊这个。而且总的来说，我们得谈谈现状。AI 又回来了，伙计们。
for a couple hours today. Bryce and I are going to record, sometime next week and that's where we got a lot of stuff. We got to talk about parrot. We got to talk about a Raybox. I've been dying to talk about it. And also in general, we got to talk about the state. AI's back folks.
我是说，它从未离开过。但它是……它真的回来了吗？当然，我们就这么说吧。我们说它回来了。关于它的讨论又回到了播客中。它比以往任何时候都更好。是的，我问这个问题与其说是为了引出播客讨论，不如说是我真的需要这个问题的答案。
I mean, it never left. But it's, is it back? Sure, we'll call it. We'll say it's back. The topic of it is back on the podcast. It's better than ever. Yeah, I asked this question less as like a podcast question to lead into a discussion. More is like, I just need an answer to the question.
所以答案是还没有。我还没试过 Claude Code。我依然沉迷于 Cursor。但是对于 Cursor，我越来越发现它对我是个“力量倍增器”，但我觉得如果我不必批准每一个命令，它可能会发挥更大的作用。在英伟达，他们说……我在邮件里看到了。而且，我们其实可以聊聊这个。
Now, so the answer is no. I have not tried Claude Code yet. still I'm still cursor-pilled. So, but with cursor, the thing I'm increasingly finding with cursor is it's been a force multiplier for me, but I think it could be a lot more of a force multiplier if I didn't have to approve the commands. And so at Nvidia, they said, I found it an email. And also, too, we can actually talk about this.
我是说，Cursor 发布了一篇文章，说英伟达有 3 万名员工是 Cursor 的日活跃用户。但我当时……我的评分达到了 168 的峰值，这让我进入了……我不知道，反正是在前百分之几。我一直很喜欢 Cursor。但这是主要问题，因为它是一个企业版，它有很多安全限制，而且它要求我们基本上批准每一个 shell 命令。
I mean, so there was an article published by cursor that said 30,000 people at Vindivida are daily active users of Cursor. But I was, I hit my peak rating of 168, which put me in the, I don't know, whatever, top percentage. And I've been really loving Cursor. And that is the main thing, though, because it's a corporate, you know, version. It has a lot of safety restrictions and a lot of that it requires us to, you know, basically approve any shell command.
但他们最近改了，现在你可以选择“全部允许”。他们在 1 月份改回来说他们正在推出一个自动批准列表，但我一直没能让它生效。所以我以为有三种模式。我以为我们版本里的模式是：批准每一个命令；允许；还有一种是带白名单的自动批准，你可以输入……
But they changed it recently so that you can now do allow all. So they changed it back in January saying that they were. rolling out an auto, you know, approve for a list of things, I have not been able to get that to work. So I thought that there were three modes. I thought the modes were, I thought the modes in our version were that there was approve every command. There was allow, there was like auto-approved with an allow list where you can enter in, like,
……可以执行的命令。然后还有一种是总是自动批准，完全的“YOLO 模式”。是的，我们没有 YOLO 模式。我以为我们有。不，我觉得你是对的。不，他们正在推出白名单，随着时间的推移，白名单将包含你所需的大部分内容。所以我的情况是，我越来越发现，因为我告诉它开始，然后……我通常会尝试去处理其他任务。
commands that are okay. And then there was like just always auto-approved like full YOLO mode. Yeah, we don't have the YOLO mode. I thought that we had it. No, I think you're right, actually. No, they're rolling out the allow list and the allow list is going to contain most of what you need over time. So here's my thing. I increasingly find, because like what I tell it to start and then, you know, I usually try to go in context to do some other task.
我还没有设置它来同时进行多个聊天，或者抱歉。Cursor 或 Claude Code。用 Cursor 的话。有时用 Cursor。Cursor 默认就是这样。你不需要设置任何东西。不，不，不，但是……我需要设置，比如 git 工作树之类的。如果我想……如果我想执行两个可能触及相同文件的任务，
I have not yet set it up to be doing like multiple chats at a time or sorry. Cursor or clog code. With cursor. Sometimes with cursor. Cursor, it's just by default. You don't have to set anything up. No, no, no, but like, like, I would need to, like, set up, like, get work trees or something. If I want to have, like, if I want to do two tasks that might touch the same files,
然后我在两个单独的聊天中启动它。哦，你是想要多个代理处理不同的任务，而不是多个代理处理单个任务以尽快获得最佳响应。不，因为我得到的响应通常已经足够好了。我不需要为每个单独的请求提供更多算力。你没有压榨它，你没有充分利用它，Bryce。我想也许我确实需要它。
and I spin that up in, like, two separate chats. Oh, you want, you want multiple agents working on different tasks, not multiple agents working on a single task to get you the best response as fast as possible. No, because, like, the responses that I do get are generally, like, good enough. Like, I don't need more power for each individual request. You're not pushing it. You're not pushing it hard enough, Bryce. I guess maybe I do need it.
我想，不，也许那不是真的，因为如果我能得到更好的响应，或者如果它花费的时间更少，那也会加速我的工作。但几乎可以肯定的是，让我越来越困扰的是命令批准。部分原因是我一直在做很多关于教育内容的工作，以及关于 DevOps 的设置，我觉得这更偏向于命令导向。它不仅仅是纯粹的写代码。它是写一些代码，然后去测试一些东西。所以我真的很想能够给它一个任务，然后让它自己去执行。我听说 Claude Code 有某种沙盒模式，
I guess, no, maybe that's not true because if it did take, if I got better responses or if it took less time, that would accelerate me too. But it almost certainly the thing that's increasingly getting me is the like command approval. And part of it's because one of the things I've been doing a lot has been working on our like educational content and on like the basically the DevOps setup for that, which I think is a little bit more like command oriented. It's not just like purely writing code. It's like write some code and then like go and test something. So I really want to be able to give it a task and then like let it go and do its own thing. What I've heard is that Claude Code has some sort of sandboxing mode
它会在沙盒中运行它的任务，作为一个沙盒，它没有网络访问权限，所以它能造成的破坏有限。我有点害怕白名单，我想。因为我觉得即使有了白名单，我也不会感到舒服，比如在生产代码库上工作时，我可能会把事情搞砸。我曾想过是否只需设置一个容器化环境，然后在容器化环境中运行 Cursor，这样它就无法访问任何能触及公司网络的东西。但是的，我很好奇你是否试过了。我想我下周某个时候会尝试设置它，因为我有一大堆积压的工作要做。我想如果能让它自己去执行任务，然后带着完整的 PR 回来让我查看，我觉得那会更好。另一件事是，我下周设置好后得给你展示一下，但我已经认定，我觉得我去英伟达以外的任何地方工作都会非常有挑战性，因为我越来越相信英伟达拥有最先进的 AI 工具供我们日常工作使用。是的，我觉得这在三六个月前可能还不是真的，但那篇关于 Cursor 的博客文章发布后，我认为这表明英伟达正在使用 Cursor。我认为这表明这里发生了一些变化。
where it will go and run its thing in a sandbox and like as a sandbox it doesn't have network access so it has like limited damage that it can do. I'm scared of the allow list, I guess. Because I think even with the allowless, I would feel uncomfortable, like, working on the production code base on a machine where, like, I could mess things up. I thought maybe about just, like, setting up a containerized environment and then in the containerized environment running a cursor where, like, it doesn't have access to anything that can touch the corporate net. But yeah, I was wondering if you tried it yet. I think I'm going to try to set it up like sometime next week because I've got a big backlog of stuff I've got to do. I think if I can have it go off and do its things on its own and then come back to me
而且我认为我们现在正在内部试用和把玩一些非常有趣的工具。对我来说很有趣的是，现在它已经成为了一项工作，我去的任何工作岗位都要求我必须能够使用 AI 编程工具。而且，你和我，我想，从来没有太担心过我们的 Token 使用预算。我认为这部分是因为我们在一家大公司，特别是在英伟达，我们的业务就是 Token 生成。但我认为其他人，你知道，那些不在这里、自己支付 Token 费用的人，受到的限制要大得多。是的。好吧，我们得结束了。而且这在技术上要到……
with like a full PR I can look at, I think that'll be better. The other thing, and I'm going to have to show you this next week once I get it fully set up, but I've come to the determination that I think that it would be very challenging me for me to go work at anywhere else it's not in video because I'm increasingly starting to believe that Navidia has the best access to AI tools to use for our day-to-day work. Yeah, I think this was maybe not true three or six months ago, but that precursor blog post that went out, like I think that's indicative about Nvidia using cursor. I think that's indicative of like a change here.
……下周才播出。但是的，我有太多话要说了。是的，我同意。我是说，我哪儿也不去。我喜欢在英伟达工作。显然，它现在是一家了不起的公司。如果我要离开，我只会考虑两家公司。一家是 Anthropic，一家是 AnySphere，也就是制作 Cursor 的公司。原因和你说的基本一样，我现在正在尝试彻底重构我思考一切的方式。是的，我也是。关于这个，我们下周会聊更多，但实际上，Shima 值得感谢，
And I think there's some pretty interesting tooling that we're like now dog fooding and playing around with. And like, it's funny to me, like, how now it's become like a job, like, a requirement for me in any job I would go to would be that I would have to be able to have access to, like, AI coding tools. And, you know, you and I, I think, have never really worried much about the budget for our token usage. And I think that that's in part because we're at a big company and at, specifically, in Vidia, where our business is the token generation. But I think that other people you know, who are not here who are paying for themselves for their tokens, you know, are a lot more constrained by that. Yeah. Well, we have to wrap this up. And this is technically already not airing till
因为我一直在构建所有这些东西，比如 Array box，Array box 后面的仪表板。我还有另一个网站，我正在写一本基于 Array box 的书。我正在构建另一个完全基于 Array box 的平台。然后我还有很多其他要构建的东西。我一直在抱怨 Descript 和这些 AI 播客编辑工具。我当时就说它们全是垃圾。我一直在向她抱怨。
next week. But yeah, I've got so much to say. Yes, I agree. I mean, I'm not going anywhere. I love working for Nvidia. Obviously, it's an amazing company to work for right now. If there are, if I were to leave, there's only two companies I would consider leaving to. One's Anthropic and one's any sphere, the company that makes cursor. For basically the same reasons that you said, like, I am now, I'm trying to completely re-architect the way that I think about everything. Yeah, me too. And this, we'll talk about this more like next week, but literally, and Shima is to think
她不停地听我没完没了地说这些工具多么神奇。她看到了我用它们在做什么。她只是……她理解为什么我现在工作得更多了，因为这太让人着迷了。用这些东西能做到的事情，这有点像……我曾在播客里听到有人说：“这难道不应该把我们从工作中解放出来吗？”但我觉得，这根本不是工作。
for this, my wife, because I've been building all this stuff, like Array box, dashboards behind Array box. I have another website and like I'm writing a book that's built on top of Array box. I'm building a whole other platform built on top of array box. And then I have a whole other things that I'm going to build. And I was whining about Descript and these AI podcast editing tools. And I was just like they're all just garbage. And I was whining about it to her.
我简直就是拿着老魔杖的哈利·波特。我不知道。总之，就是某种魔杖。就像终极魔杖。感觉就是这样。我一直在抱怨这些东西。
And she hears me like nonstop ad nauseum saying how amazing these tools are. And she sees what I'm doing with it. And she's just like, she understands why like I work more now because it is intoxicated. what you were able to do with this stuff, which is kind of like, I've heard on podcast being like, wasn't this supposed to free us from work? And it's like, this is not work.
她就说：“你为什么不自己去构建一个播客编辑器呢？”因为我想身处这个世界。我每周花那么多小时在内容创作上，只是为了去除“嗯”声，清理音频轨道，所有这些事情。
I am, I am Harry Potter with the elder, the elder wand. I don't know. Anyways, there's some wand. It's like the ultimate wand. That's what it feels like. And I was wanting about this stuff.
而且 AI 在某一点上将能够完成所有这些工作。我仍然想要创意控制权，比如什么时候插入来自电影、歌曲或广告的轨道。我当时就说，好吧，要取代 Audacity 以及我想要的那些功能，这任务太艰巨了。但后来我一想，我为什么不能做呢？五个小时后，我有了这个极简的东西。现在，我意识到我对一切都有抱怨，
And she's like, why don't you just go build your own podcast editor? Because like I want to be in the world. Like I spend so many hours a week on like content creation of just like removing ums, cleaning up audio tracks, like, you know, all this stuff.
比如我使用的播客播放器。比如……总之，我意识到我有能力构建这个世界，我打算去把它造出来。实际上，我只需要一天里的时间，人们会问：“你为什么要创建自己的播客播放器？”我花在编辑和收听播客上的时间比我认识的任何人都多，而且我对好的设计有非常非常好的直觉，我们总是抱怨。但最重要的是，你花了很多时间做编辑，所以为什么不自动化呢？正是如此。另一件事是，即使只是收听播客，也有很多抱怨。
and like AI will be able to do it all at one point. I still want creative control of when I insert like tracks from some, you know, a movie or song or whatever or some, you know, advertisement. And I was just like, well, it's a pretty tall task to like replace audacity, the features that I want from it. But then I was thinking and I was like, well, I do, why, why can't I do it? Five hours later, I have this like minimal thing. And now, like, I've realized that I have complaints about everything,
我有，你知道，超级简单的想法。首先，播客播放器里绝对没有任何广告。我不想靠这个赚钱。我想要这个是为了我自己，这样体验更好。第二件事，所以没有广告，但如果我们能做得更好呢？如果我能用 AI 自动为我跳过广告呢？在《The Daily》里，开头是 30 秒，中间是 60 秒，有时结尾还有 15 秒。在其他播客里，开头可能有 8 分钟，但只有 10 秒。如果这火了，你会被所有播客创作者封杀的，他们会说：
like the podcast players that I use. Like, like, and, Anyway, so I just realized, like, I have the ability to build the world, and I'm just going to go build it. Literally, it's just the time in the day that I need in order, and people like, why would you go create your own podcast player? I spend more time editing and listening to podcasts than any person I know, and I have a very, very good, like, intuition for, like, good design and, like, we always whine about. But most importantly, like, you spend a lot of time doing the editing, so why not automate it? Exactly. And the other thing is, even just consuming podcasts, like, there are so many complaints.
“嘿，你抢了我的收入。”你知道吗？我们在 Chrome 上有广告拦截器。而且，我已经在手动跳过广告了。是的。就是这样，这就是重点，我知道。我知道《The Daily》开头有 30 秒广告，中间有 60 秒。而且我设置了我的播客播放器。你可以自定义跳过 30 秒，后退 10 秒。总之。而且，我使用的播客播放器 CastBox 太糟糕了。它有所有这些社区功能。它有所有这些热门播客。问题是，我想切换到 Spotify。
that I have and like, you know, super simple ideas. First of all, no, no ads at all in the podcast player. I don't want to make money off of this thing. I wanted this for myself, so it's a better experience. Second thing, so that's, it's no ads, but what if we could do better? What if I could use AI to skip, automatically skip the ads for me? In the daily, it's 30 seconds at the beginning, 60 seconds in the middle, sometimes, you know, 15 seconds at the end before the other things you need to know. In other podcasts, it's like, you know, eight minutes at the beginning of the podcast but 10 seconds. If this takes off, you're going to get canceled by all the podcast creators who are going to be like,
他们没有播放队列。什么播客播放器……是的，我用 Podcast Addict，因为我在用安卓。这还可以，但不是……是的，我也有很多同样的问题。没有一个是好的。Shima 说，甚至我还在玩她的 Apple Podcast，因为她用 iPhone。她说：“哦，我有太多抱怨了。”
hey, you take it my revenue. You know what? We've got ad blockers on Chrome. And, you know, I'm already skipping the ads myself manually. Yeah. Just like, and that's the thing is like, I know. I know. That's why I know the daily has 30 seconds.
和 CastBox 发生的情况一样，过了几天，如果你没听，它就会从你的设备上删除。他们把下载的剧集和……总之，重点是，我们得专门做一期节目来聊聊“点子大王”这件事。多年来我有过那么多点子，只是没有时间或知识去实现。我以前绝不会去创建自己的播客播放器应用。但现在，你可能在周末一天内就能做到。这就是为什么我觉得我需要优先考虑设置沙盒，因为我一直在查看我的待办事项列表，我有一大堆积压的工作，我知道项目的范围。我知道如何准确描述需要完成的事情。
I add at the beginning, 60 in the middle. And like, I have my podcast player set up. You can customize like the skip ahead 30, skip back 10. Like, like, anyways. And also, too, like, there's just, in the podcast player that I use CastBox, it's so awful. It's got all these community features. It's got all these, like, top podcasts. And the thing is, I want to switch to Spotify.
如果有人给我一个草稿，我就能引导它完成。我只是……但我有 20 个这样的任务。如果我使用 AI 的方式是监控它逐个完成这 20 个任务，那是不行的。但如果我能告诉它：“做这 20 件事，然后回来找我”，然后花一天时间审查这 20 件事。这是一个可能奖励 ADHD 患者的世界。总之，我该让你走了。
They don't have a queue. What podcast player in their... Yeah, it's like, I use podcast addict and it's like, okay, because I'm on Android. And it's like, okay, but not... Yeah, like, a lot of the same problems I have to. None of them are good. And Shima was saying that even I was playing around with her Apple podcast because she's on iPhone. And she was like, oh, I've got so many complaints.
是的。我得……这太悲伤了，真的。我本该在 20 分钟前就停止录制的。但我太兴奋了，想聊这些东西。我从两个不同的播客里录了两个片段。其中一个是 Peter Steinberger，做 OpenClaw 的那个人，以前叫 Moldclaw，以前叫 Claude a bot。天哪，他就是……其中一句名言是：“一个好的司机可以从这些模型中的任何一个获得结果。”然后还有一个人，做 Ghosty Hashimoto 的那个人，他说的正是你所说的，他对使用的模型非常挑剔，比如 Haiku、Librarian。
The same thing that happens on CastBox is like after a certain number of days, if you haven't listened to it, it like removes it from your device. They separate downloaded episodes versus the, anyway, the point being there's a whole episode we have to have on like, you know, just being like an idea guy. Like I have had so many ideas for so many years that I just didn't have the time or the knowledge to like go and implement. Like I would never go create my own podcast player like app. But now like you could probably do that in a day on a weekend like the idea. person thing is why I think I need to prioritize getting like the sandboxing set up because I've had this big, I was just going through my to do list and I had this big backlog of like things that like I know I know the scope of the project. I know exactly how to describe what needs to be
还有另一个。所以对于简单的任务，他会委派给它们。我也一样。总之，有太多东西要聊了。我们就聊到这儿吧。也许我会下周发布这期节目，然后你们就能听到我们……好吧，也许我们……总之，我会搞定的。要聊的东西太多了。你还有最后一句话要说吗？播客没什么要说的。好吧，我想这确实是给播客的，那就是我们过去讨论过并出现过的两个嘉宾人选。我的待办事项列表里有要考虑他们。一个是 Chris Leary，他是主要成员之一。他提到了，是的。
done. And if like if a draft of it is presented to me, I can I can direct it to the finish line. I just like, but I have like 20 of these things. I can't if the way that I'm using AI is that I'm like monitoring, like, you know, monitoring it doing each one of those 20 tasks serially, it's not going to work. But if I can go and tell it, like, do these 20 things, come back to me and then spend a day reviewing those 20 things. It's a world that reward may reward people with ADHD. But anyways, I should let you go.
我们已经聊过他了。他是 J.F 在 TLB 的联合主持人。我们要联系他看看能不能安排时间录制吗？暂时不要。因为我们下周或下下周要录制很多内容，大概会有三四期节目的量。安排在今年晚些时候吧。
Yeah. And I got to, it's so sad, though, though, and that's the thing. I was supposed to stop recording 20 minutes ago. And then it's just, I'm so excited to talk about this stuff. I've recorded two different clips from two different podcasts. and one of them is from the Peter Steinberger, the guy that did OpenClaw, formerly Moldclaw, formerly Claude, a bot. And, oh my God, it's just, he's just like, you get, one of the quotes is a good driver can get results from any of these models. And then there was, I didn't clip it, but there was a guy, the guy that is doing ghosty Hashimoto, you know, he's, he was saying that, like, he was talking about exactly what you're saying is that he's very specific about which models he uses, you know, haiku librarian.
那是真的。那是真的。另一个是……我是说，如果这要上播客，我想他可能会发现，因为认识他的人可能会告诉他。是的，另一个是请 Emily Berger 来。是的，我们也可以请他来。Carpathie 怎么了？请 Carpathie 来？没回我的邮件。来吧，Carpathie。通往 Carpathie 之路。走吧。因为这就是 Bryce 和我线下聊的内容。谁知道有多少
one other one. So for the simple tasks, he delegates there. And I do the same. Anyways, there's so much stuff to talk about. We'll leave it there. Maybe I will release this episode next week and then you'll be hearing us. Well, maybe we're, anyway, I'll figure it out. It's too much stuff to talk about. You got one final thing to say. Nothing for the podcast. Well, okay, I guess it is for the podcast, which is we've, there's two guest ideas that we've talked about in the past and that have come up. And I have on my to-do list to, like, think about them. And it's a Chris Leary, who is one of the main guys He came up, yeah.
内容能播出来，但关于我想聊的嘉宾。是的，老实说，我以前是编程语言先生，算法先生。我仍然喜欢那些东西，但说实话，编程语言不再重要了。点子才重要。实际上，我和我的老板 Michael 聊过。他说：“不，点子一文不值。洞察力才是最重要的。洞察力是值得保留的点子。”我喜欢那句名言。
We've already talked about him. He's J.F's co-host of TLB. Do we want to reach out to him and see about scheduling any time to record with him? Not yet. Because we're going to record a lot next week or the week after, which is going to be like three or four episodes of content. Schedule it after later in the year.
我喜欢那句名言。我要把它印在 T 恤上。洞察力？好吧。那是非常 Michael Garland 的话。是的。但像 Ilya Sutskever，Andrei Karpathy，还有我提到的其他人？有四个人，我还没想出第五个我想聊的人。
That's true. That's true. And the other one would be... I mean, if this is going to be on the podcast, I guess he's potentially going to find out because someone who knows him might let him know. Yeah, the other would be to have Emily Berger on. Yeah, we could get him on as well. What happened to Carpathie? Have Carpathie on? Didn't reply to my emails. Come on, Carpathie. The path to Carpathie. Let's go. Because that's what Bryce and I were talking offline. Who knows how much
你知道，Dario Amodei，他太像 CEO 了。我不想和 Sam Altman 聊。我不想。哦，是的。Demis Hassabis。他绝对是前三名。总之，还有几个。如果我们能请到这些人，但他们太……我们还不够大。
of this makes it in, but about like the guests that I want to talk to. Yeah. And honestly, I was like, you know, I used to be programming, Mr. Programming Languages, Mr. Algorithms. I still love that stuff, but like, let's be honest, programming languages don't matter anymore. Ideas matter. And actually, I was talking to Michael, my boss. And he was like, no, ideas are a dime in a dozen. Insights are what matters. Insights are ideas worth keeping. And I love that quote.
我们是前 5% 的播客，但我们不是前 0.1%。我觉得我们应该联系一两个人，看看能不能安排今年晚些时候的时间，否则我们只会谈论嘉宾而不会真的请他们来。所以这是一个，怎么说呢，ADSP 承诺？就是 Bryce 和我下次录制之后，我们会有一个嘉宾。是的。可能不是我们刚才提到的任何人。你现在可能甚至听不到这个。
I love that quote. I'm going to put it on a T-shirt. Insights? All right. That's a very Michael Garland quote. Yeah. But like Ilya Susskever, Andrei Carpathie, who are the other people that I mentioned? There was four people and I couldn't figure out a fifth that I wanted to talk to.
请务必查看这些节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的口号。那不是口号。
You know, Dario Amadee, he's too CEO-ish. I don't want to talk to Sam Altman. I don't. Oh, yeah. Demis Sassavis. He's definitely top three. Anyways, there's a couple others. If we could get those people on, but they're just, they're two, we're not a big enough.
我们的口号是“混乱中撒点信息”。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可留下评论。
We're top five percent podcast, but we're not a top point one, you know? I think that, like, I think we ought to reach out to one or two people and see if we can schedule something for later in the air, because otherwise we'll just talk about guests and not actually pull them on. So here's a, what do you call it, ADSP, ADSP promise? Is that the next time Bryce and I record after the next time, we'll have a. guest. Yeah. Might not be any of the people we just mentioned. You might not even be hearing this right now.
我们是排名前百分之五的播客，但还算不上前百分之零点一，你知道吧？我觉得我们应该联系一两个人，看看能不能安排一下今年晚些时候的录制，否则我们只会一直谈论嘉宾却从不邀请他们。所以，这算是一个ADSP承诺吗？就是说，在下下次我和Bryce录音的时候，我们会请一位嘉宾。当然，可能不是我们刚才提到的那些人。你现在听到的可能甚至都不是那一期。
Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast. com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline.
请务必查看节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用中，还是在ADSPthepodcast.com网站上，那里有我们今天节目中提到的所有内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有愉快的一天。低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的标语。其实那不是标语。
Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的标语是：充满混乱，点缀知识。这一集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。